[Musique]
jean paul drouillon vous êtes né à
gaillon quel est votre plus vieux
souvenirs qui concerne votre ville
natale à part l'école peut-être alors
parce que c'est pas mal de venir à
l'école ce que c'est vraiment le premier
souvenir ce que c'est la première école
4 m en dos et ça c'est vraiment le grand
souvenir le dr bon là ça fait sept ou
huit ans que j'ai prévenu je prends des
bouffées de souvenirs d'un seul coup et
l'école c'est important de dire sa
première école celle d'antan souvient
mieux
et alors bon gaillon ça a été là où j'ai
découvert la vie où tout est tout
découvert les bienfaits toujours aller
voir
je vous présente mon premier instituteur
est lé premier il compte beaucoup
on s'en souvient a tout le temps c'est
pour ça que j'ai toujours plaisir à
revoir monsieur raymond d'eau c'est lui
qui va tout après finalement tout va
bien la trahir
voilà j'essaie exécution il ya un truc
nombreux jeunes surtout bouillon avait
huit salles consolide ce bien est sortie
de la récession
je vais pas être content je veux dire la
vérité
c'était un garçon charmant tu prends de
lévriers cet état
un bonnet les impôts neil il était plein
de veiller surtout plein de vie je crois
qu'il est toujours resté gentili s'en
sort bien ce qui est important est que
si roman dos et que grâce à lui que j'ai
découvert ma première cellule
photoélectrique par la passionnée de
photo il faisait déjà les photos
à cette époque là et alors c'est
impressionnant de voir ces petites
boîtes il nous l'avait été la juste sur
le pont pour voir si c'est sa mesure est
selon lui la flemme ou l'intelligence
on était tous très impressionnés par
toucher le poteau les crimes qu'il est
pour quelque chose peut-être dans ma
carrière c'est un et bien ça commençait
en 65
j'étais monté à paris comme on dit pour
faire ce métier
alors je me suis demandé bon peut-être
que je prenne des cours et cetera puis
un jour le tout mon courage à deux mains
je suis allé au tnp parce que le tnp
fonds était le grand théâtre de paris
c'est la cour avait commencé et au flanc
je vais aller demandé à la dame qui vont
des places qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire
pour jouer dans le théâtre du musée par
mon travail et regarder la cub jéhovah
vous êtes complètement fou adressez-vous
à l'administration
l'administration c'est important face
ouvert la porte et là avant que j'ouvre
la bouche on m'a dit ah vous venez pour
l'audition troisième sous-sol gelé au
troisième sous-sol il y avait 40
personnes pour pâques attendait j'ai
fait la queue comme les autres et puis
bon c'est tombé sur moi on m'a choisi
pour un petit rôle et puis c'est parti
de là
donc voilà longtemps enfin je reparle
après midi aux milliers me vois qu'on
boive un coup ouais hein
alors il faut bien parler du rôle qui
nous a rendus célèbres celui que vous
avez joué dans les brigades du tigre qui
ont fait pour ainsi dire votre célébrité
will commissaire valentin et wyatte du
tigre moi je n'ai que des bons souvenirs
de cette série parce que c'est d'avoir
une équipe on est 3 qui ce qu'ils t'ont
pas et c c'est le succès d'une équipe et
puis d'un auteur aussi qu'elle suit bien
retracer une époque dans l'humour et en
même temps intéressante et cédric un
impact sur tout le monde enfin je veux
dire les jeunes comme les plus âgés
on a très bien marché j'aime beaucoup
bah oui parce que les gens n'aient des
projets cinéma mais on est un peu
superstitieux dans ce métier dans la
mesure où ce n'est pas signé on n'ose
pas trop en parler alors j'espère que ni
un bon coup qui se prépare là on en
reparlera ce moment là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]